dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir as we know from
the series neural network based
techniques are extraordinarily
successful in defeating problems that
were considered to be absolutely
impossible as little as ten years ago
when we'd like to use them for something
choosing the right kind of neural
network is one part of the task but
usually the even bigger problem is
choosing the right architecture
architecture typically at the bare
minimum means the type and number of
layers in the network and the number of
neurons to be used in each layer bigger
networks can learn solutions for more
complex problems so it seems that the
answer is quite easy just throw the
biggest possible neural network we can
at the problem and hope for the best but
if you think that it is that easy or
trivial you need to think again here's
why bigger networks come at a cost they
take longer to Train and even worse if
we have networks that are too big we
bump into the problem of overfitting
overfitting is a phenomenon when a
learning algorithm starts essentially
memorizing the training data without
actually doing the learning as a result
its knowledge is not going to generalize
for unseen data at all imagine a student
in a school who has the tremendous
aptitude in memorizing everything from
the textbook if the exam questions
happen to be the same this student will
do extremely well but in the case of
even the slightest deviations well too
bad even though people like to call this
rote learning there is nothing about the
whole process that resembles any kind of
learning at all a smaller neural network
a less knowledgeable student who has
done their homework properly would do
way way better so this is overfitting
the bane of so many modern learning
algorithms it can be kind of defeated by
using techniques like l1 and l2
regularization or dropout these often
help but none of them are silver bullets
if you would like to hear more about
these we've covered them in an earlier
episode actually two episodes as always
the links are in the video description
for the more curious fellow scholars out
there so the algorithm itself is
learning but for some reason we have to
design there
architecture by hand as we discussed
some architectures like some students of
course significantly outperform other
ones and we are left to perform a
lengthy trial and error to find the best
ones by hand so speaking about learning
algorithms why don't we make them learn
their own architectures and this new
algorithm is about architecture search
that does exactly that
I note that this is by far not the first
crack at this problem but it definitely
is a remarkable improvement over the
state of the art it represents the
neural network architecture as an
organism and makes it evolve via genetic
programming this is just as cool as you
would think it is and not half as
complex as you may imagine at first we
have an earlier episode on genetic
algorithms I wrote some source code as
well which is available free of charge
for everyone make sure to have a look at
the video description for more on that
you'll love it
in this chart you can see the member of
evolution steps on the horizontal x-axis
and the performance of these evolved
architectures over time on the vertical
y-axis finally after taking about one
and a half days to perform these few
thousand evolutionary steps the best
architectures found by this algorithm
are only slightly inferior to the best
existing neural networks for many
classical datasets which is bloody
amazing please refer to the paper for
details and comparisons against the
state-of-the-art neural networks and
other architecture search approaches
there are lots of very easily readable
results reported there
note that this is still a preliminary
work and uses hundreds of graphics cards
in the process however if you remember
how it went with alphago the
computational cost were cut down by a
factor of ten within a little more than
a year and until that happens we have
learning algorithms that learn to
optimize themselves this sounds like
science fiction how cool is that thanks
for watching and for your generous
support and I'll see you next time
[Music]